once you've got that in there what I
also want to add on these are the last
two objects after the focus is something
which sort of reflect off of the
parabola okay so what I want you to
imagine is go back to the satellite dish
picture right so space is up here here's
our satellite dish okay space is up here
and radiation electromagnetic radiation
is coming down to the satellite dish and
it's all coming from the same direction
from our point of view it's coming from
up to down okay so therefore it's all
parallel to the y-axis does that make
sense
so what I want you to draw in is like a
ray of light or something like that
that comes from space and intersects
hits that point of intersection there
right so it's going to be a vertical
line like so it's parallel to the y-axis
but it collides with this point of
intersection let's call that point of
intersection P now it's going to reflect
off of this some point here but remember
because I said to you before the
parabola is just like the tangent at
that point right in fact at that point
it might as well be the tangent it's
going to bounce off in a physics way
that I'm going to refer to later but
it's going to look something like this
okay now what's the exact nature of that
of that bouncing well we're going to
prove that so let's put on some actual
you know labels and algebra this is
where mathematics departs from physics
and says okay we're going to get into
the nuts and bolts of this geometrically
and prove what's going on well on the
satellite dish there was something in
the focus maybe you didn't I didn't
point it out so maybe didn't notice it
and on the on the headlight there was
also something there so we'll come to
that a bit later
all right let's label a few more things
okay and what do we usually call the
focus s and what are its coordinates
zero a comma a which is correct if this
is a particular kind of parabola what
would the what assumption am i making
about this parabola
it's x squared equals 401 and there's no
reason why not to work with this in this
case I'm trying to prove a property
about parabolas in general so I might as
well just use it use an easy using
parabola right that's there if that's
the case then what are the coordinates
of P how can I state that I could call
it x1 y1 if I was talking in Cartesian
terms but being at the moment like I set
the terms a question hasn't been given
to me in one form or the other so I can
choose Cartesian form or parametric form
so which do you think might be more
useful in this case because I'm
interested in things bouncing off angles
and that kind of thing
angles means gradients in the context of
corn geometry so therefore gradients
means parameters okay so I'm going to go
for 2 AP AP squared okay I've got that
I've got that there's that vertical line
there just for the sake of it we're not
actually gonna use it but you guys can
tell me what is the equation of this
vertical line have a think about it look
this it's okay so it's a it's a vertical
line so is it gonna be x equals or y
equals it's gonna be x equals and I get
its x value from where it passes through
namely oh okay we won't need that fact
but it's good to have it for the sake of
completeness like there's a line there
we should know what it is okay now I
have a tangent at paint right now
early on this was on the very first
objects we had a look at when we
introduced the parameter we found out
the equation of a tangent in terms of
the parameter the form that I believe we
came up with started with y equals does
anyone has anyone used it enough to know
what it is it was in it was actually in
slope-intercept form whichever remembers
they're not all in slope-intercept form
but this one is I think you'll find it's
P X and you should have known that bit
right come on
think how did you enjoy that even if you
don't know what the rest of you is how
do you do that yeah because if it's in
slope-intercept form well you're going
to get the slope from the slope of the
point you're going through right that's
what makes a detention does anyone
remember what the extra bits are it's
close ay
squared okay so there is a square there
is a parameter in there no Q's cuz
different parameter okay so far so good
now this is almost all I need to get
through this if you have another color
bo this next bit might be helpful to do
with another color this point down here
is quite important this point down here
I'm going to label it okay it's not a
normal point we're interested in but
given the information that you have at
your disposal you can tell me what the
coordinates of K are let's do the easy
one what's the x-coordinate zero it's on
the y axis after all now look carefully
that point K is the y-intercept of this
tangent so therefore its y-coordinate
must be have a look
hello this is in slope intercept form
right so there it is right there - AP
squared which is a relief because you
know there it is down in the bottom half
of the Cartesian plane so that looks
good okay so now we can start to dissect
what is going on can you see that I've
got all these angles in here but there
there's lots of angles that are related
to each other for instance see this
angle down here let's call it theta
there's a bunch of angles in this
diagram that are equal to theta some are
obvious some not so much
okay do you notice for example that
you've got the Y axis and it's parallel
to another line is diagram which line is
that yeah it's parallel to this x equals
to AP vertical line okay so you've got a
parallel line here and here we know lots
of things about parallel lines what
angle can you tell me is equal to this
have a look okay now I don't I don't I
don't actually have enough labels here
to be able to describe this so I've got
coordinates here do you want to like
name some coordinates up here you want
to introduce some letters
I'm gonna call say I said this was like
a ray of you know light or radiation or
whatever so let's call that R this is on
the tangent so maybe we'll call that T
all right now can you see therefore that
angle R P
hey Engel RPT that's some related to
this angle in what way can you see it
have a look mm-hmm
our PT sk p i guess is where it is
aren't these guys facing the same
direction if they're both attached to
parallel line so we call these guys it
corresponding angles aren't they in fact
now that I label it if you turn your
head sideways you can sort of see the F
country it's a really mean over F if you
look at it yeah you should turn your
head that's it okay so you can see the F
that makes a car spear corresponding
angles so that's we should write that
down
so I'm going to say angle s KP equals
angle what do we call it have a look ah
PT and the reason was corresponding
angles are equal on parallel lines I'll
just leave that there
okay that looks good now pause for a
moment and put your pens down how many
of you do physics how many people do
physics here about half the room okay
great now I did not do physics so I
didn't have language to describe what
I'm about to say to you but everyone has
a vague sense at least with intuition
that this is true if you have something
like a ray of light bouncing off another
surface okay
at the moment it's it's bouncing off
this parabola right that's the object
that's actually there the saddle idea or
the headlight or that kind of thing but
as we were just discovering if we look
at this part of the parabola where it's
bouncing off it might as well be the
tangent okay so therefore I can say it's
acting as if it's bouncing off this
thing
this thing doesn't exist it's just a
construction we put in but it behaves so
much like the parabola at that point I
can say that it is the parabola at that
point when it bounces off this angle
here that now I know is Theta is what we
call the angle of physics people want to
tell me what it is it's the angle of
incidence
that's worth writing down especially if
you're a non physics person because this
is not language that you're used to
hearing now the angle of incidence here
theta if it's bouncing off a flat
surface should be exactly equal to this
angle over here what's this called the
angle of refraction is often what this
is called it's not the only name further
or the only designation for the angle of
reflection but I think it's a pretty
good understanding of what's going on it
comes in at this angle it goes away it
reflects at that angle so I'm hoping to
prove that that angle in there is also
theta I don't know it to be the case yet
so I'm going to pause for a moment I
want you to look at all the information
that is there if your goal was to show
that not only is this these are not only
are these angles theta but I think this
angle is also theta how would you go
about doing it I'm gonna give you a
minute or two just to have a look at it
don't let construct a proof or anything
like that but maybe put if these three
things on your diagram how would you go
about establishing that that was also
theta because that establishes this
reflective property that we were talking
about have a think I'll give you a
moment to reflect okay see what I did